yeah well thanks Cynthia I'm really
excited that so many people manage to
show up on a Saturday afternoon setting
outside you could be doing something
else so yeah this is about I think an
interesting connection between matrix
completion and private single vector
computation I want to tell you about and
I try to keep the talk sort of
lightweight because it's Saturday but if
you want more sort of hardcore details i
will use the whiteboard and you're at
your recommendation so what a single
vector computation well the first single
effector is just defined as the vector u
that maximize the norm of a times u
divided by the norm of you ok so that
defines the top single effector I assume
everybody knows that and the you can
define the first k single vector is
recursively by searching or by
maximizing this objective function
orthogonal to the previous vectors that
you found so that those are the top
singlet vectors of the matrix these are
the things we're interested in in this
talk okay so in my opinion there's sort
of three epochs in singler vector
computation so the first one started
with koshi in the 19th century in 1829
when he came up with spectral theory and
a lot of the math were using today is
still you know from the 19th century but
we didn't have efficient algorithms back
then if you want efficient algorithms
you had to wait until von Mises
discovered the power method in 1929
exactly hundred years later and this was
the first effective force practical
method for computing singular vectors
and then numerical analysis kicked in
and there were lots of results on
efficient algorithms ok so what are we
doing today I don't know about 21st
century and in general and I don't know
what's going to happen in 20 29 but
today we sort of focus on data sets and
this is what this program at Berkeley is
about and what's workshop is about in
part and we focus on properties of data
sets and how they change a single
erector computation or the objective
that we have so for example in this talk
will be relevant is that a lot of data
sets are very noisy or have missing
values or come with privacy concerns and
we still be able to analyze them using
single avec to computation while you
know making sense of these objectives or
out of these concerns and so we're
somehow back to where co she was that we
have a lot of good questions but we
don't really know if they're efficient
algorithms for them okay so that's that
sort of the background and one
respective problem in this family is the
matrix completion problem it's a
beautiful problem where you're trying to
compute or you given a matrix like this
and you're only seeing a subset of the
entries you're not seeing all entries
okay it's just a subset of the entries
don't think of the missing entries at
zero they're actually not there okay so
you don't know the full mint and matrix
and you want to reconstruct the missing
entries of this partially given matrix
and the way we're going to think about
this is that we really want to
approximate the dominant singular
vectors of the unknown matrix so not the
subsample but the matrix that we don't
know using the information that we have
so and if we have the dominant single
vectors of the unknown matrix then that
also gives us low reconstruction error
okay so then we can also figure out what
these entries are up to some error and
this is sometimes called the netflix
problem because their weight it's not
quite we're not quite there yet the
multi we're so this is also called the
netflix problem because you can think of
rows or as movies & and columns as users
and these correspond to user movie
ratings and if you could reconstruct the
missing entries you could do
recommendation pretty well unfortunately
the problem in full generalities and be
hard there's very little you can say
without making further assumptions but
people have studied this problem quite a
bit starting with and have figured out
assumptions that make the problem
tractable starting with a beautiful work
by Conda Tsingtao people have figured
out a set of assumptions under which you
can actually prove interesting things
about this problem okay so what are
these assumptions I want to quickly go
over them the first one is very natural
you assume that the matrix is
approximately low rank okay so it's
approximately rank K where K is a
parameter that's much less than n okay
so this is a very natural assumption and
satisfied by a lot of matrices arm and
that means that the the top casing the
vectors are very informative and you
don't need to you
no need to know the rest the second
assumption we're going to make us in
coherence it came up in some of the
talks but I want to state it again we're
going to assume that the top singlet
space so the space spent by the top k
singular vectors is incoherent and what
does that mean that means if you look at
any standard basis vector e I and you
projected onto the space you you get a
vector of small norm okay so formally if
you look at AI transpose u and compute
the norm of that that's that's a short
vector okay so it's much much less than
one that's in coherence okay these norms
are also sometimes called the leverage
scores come up a lot in a lot of
settings and you want them to be small
okay it's important assumption finally
you're going to assume that the the
subsample is nice okay so this is not
the only assumption we need we also need
that the subsample is nice and the
easiest way of saying that is that the
subsample is chosen uniformly at random
okay which is strong assumption but it's
sort of dual to this incoherence
assumption in the sense that these are
really twin assumptions so if you if you
have an incoherent matrix what you want
is a random subsample if you have a
random subsample what you need is an
incoherent matrix so together these make
a lot of sense and you can you can
change them if you're sub-samples bias
then i can tell you how you need to
change the leverage scores so that you
can do the same so these are the
assumptions that people propose and are
by now standard in this community sorry
all of them simultaneously oh there's
one more we're also going to assume that
it never rains in San Francisco to
choose a reasonable assumption and we're
just going to assume them people that
know I can say whatever I want right so
people don't object to these assumptions
anymore actually I'm just making this up
so we don't need that it never rains in
San Francisco okay my point here is that
these assumptions are strong but in
hindsight they led to an informative
theory okay they like to very
interesting theorems and so I am
actually not that pessimistic about
these assumptions even though they are
strong yeah
the subsample uniformly random
assumptions oh so of a certain density
of a certain density so use include
every entry and your soo there a set of
entries that you know and every entry is
included with probability P an
dependency sorry so yeah the way I think
about this problem you're given a
subsample of the entries and that some
sample has to be chosen uniformly at
random of a certain density or let's say
every entries iid chosen with some
probability P so this is exactly the
quantitative question how many how many
samples do you need to to get a good
result to recover the matrix that's
exactly the question people study in
this line of work yeah this did a nice
geometric interpretation of the bus
condition the first condition Rose
doesn't hit the rim no thank goodness oh
they incur your anything um yeah so it
some houses that I mean another way to
think about is that all the singular
vectors of the matrix are smooth so they
have some all infinity norm because this
is essentially what you're seeing there
AI transpose u is the is row of the
matrix you and that has to be half small
norm and since it has only the row has
only k entries that means all the
entries have to be small so it's more or
less equivalent to saying that the
singular vectors have to have small L
infinity norm relative yeah they're off
norm one Morgan so that's one way to
think about it there are other ways it
won't really need okay so these are the
assumptions we're going to work with
which are standard in this line of work
and under these assumptions there's been
a lot of work ins it's a little bit hard
to summarize it on one slide but here's
essentially what's happening so there is
a very nice interesting algorithm a
convex minimization algorithm called the
nuclear norm approach which has amazing
provable bounce so they they're very
close to two optimal and optimal means
the number of samples has to be
something like since Nina asked we're
going to write this down more formally
so nuclear norm needs the ample sized
about order k mu times n log in ok so
where K is the rank use the coherence
parameter and as you can see it's very
close to linear and then even though
they're N squared entries so you need
much less than N squared you need only
about linearly many entries so that's
what nuclear norm gets you it's very
close to optimal unfortunately the
algorithms very slow it takes cubic time
to for it to to to run at sakana it's a
semi definite programming and there's an
alternative approach called alternating
minimization that's sort of the method
of choice in practice it works amazingly
well in practice and the running time is
incredible it's a nearly denia in the in
the number of entries that you have and
unfortunately the provable sample size
bound so the practical the empirical
sample size is great but what we can
prove about it is very not not well
understood so that the bouncy are very
high they're like k to the seventh and
some other stuff ok so one thing we're
going to see in this talk yeah I should
say that the first bounds over here that
were due to cache of on and pratik who's
was he at the workshop and co-authors
and it was amazing that they could
analyze this algorithm at all so you
know even those algum has been around
for ten years it's only now that we have
approval bounds for it so this was a
really nice paper in practice you always
use alternating minimization and in
practice you typically don't have you
know your matrix doesn't satisfy very
strong assumptions so this is
alternating minimization is also very
nice tolerant okay so what we're going
to see one thing we're going to see in
this talk is techniques that allow you
to analyze alternating minimization in a
better way so we're going to say that we
are going to see that we can actually
get pretty close to the optimal so we're
going to get something quadratic and k
instead of K to the seventh and we're
going to keep the running time in nearly
linear and n so I think there's now hope
that we'll we'll be able to get the
optimal sample size at some point using
alternating minimization you think it's
a true theorem and we get a lot closer
to that okay so whether that's
basically one teaser one thing you're
going to learn in this talk again this
algum is based on alternating
minimization you can soon on the archive
recent work but that's only one of two
things I want to talk about okay and
this is where malta gets excited because
there's also the other netflix problem
which is you know privacy and this is
where you know insert a dramatic
reference to Narayana and schmatta Cove
so you know please take note that I
follow the convention in differential
privacy I hope you all attended Malta's
talk at the rump session so yeah so
basically you know you can also use the
subsample of the matrix to re-identify
users which you might want to avoid and
so the question that we're also going to
study in this talk is private single
vector computation ok so the most basic
way to formalize this is given a matrix
a find or approximate the top-k singular
vectors subject to differential privacy
a very simple can you do single vector
computation under differential privacy
and how well can you do it and there's
been lots of work something out which we
will see in the an exciting recent work
the canals going to talk about next
session but it's been studying a lot
since the early work by Offerman and
this is here and Frank and Kobe so it's
an exciting line of work and want to
tell you what we can say about it so
using the same techniques that or using
the techniques I'll tell you about in
this talk we can get a nearly linear
time algorithm for computing in the top
k singlet vectors of a matrix under
differential privacy with the following
guarantees if you want to talk about
entry level privacy so differential
privacy is going to protect against
changing a single entry in the matrix
that's one privacy notion that you could
come up with then we get the nearly
optimal error dependence in terms of the
rank K so the target renke not the rank
of the matrix and the coherence of the
matrix ok so it turns out that for entry
privacy the relevant parameters are just
k and the coherence ok and without
stating what the Bounty's we get
essentially nearly optimal dependence
there we only have a logarithmic
dependence in n ok so this bound is
essentially dimension for
which is surprising that you know you
you have something that's dimension free
in under differential privacy yeah n is
the number of people of n so it's a it's
the algorithm runs in time n times K
squared times log in ok good question so
yeah I mean the doctor lawyer the air
buns depend a little bit on what
objective function you choose their
multiple choices so don't want to bug
you down with the formal details but
that that's all in the paper and this
algum gets epsilon delta differential
privacy it does not work currently for
epsilon zero and i should say that this
result the main question that Aaron and
I left open a previous work where we
wanted to have the tight dependence for
any K we only got four K equals to one
Aaron used to offer at previous
workshops $500 i still haven't seen
those I don't know what's going on
pretty stingy in my opinion um but okay
right by John Albert money for a
negative resolution but okay then that's
um pretty not happening I thought it
fries was supposed to be funded
something established from the twitter
IPO let's move on so there's also you
can talk about you know unit spectral
norm or privacy under unit spectral norm
changes so instead of changing a single
entry you're protecting against i change
to the matrix of unit spectral norm okay
so you can add and remove any matrix of
units spectral norm that's a much
stronger privacy guarantee you're
allowed to do much more were you
protecting against much more so that's
the advantage is stronger privacy
guarantee the disadvantage is it's you
don't get a dependence on the coherency
instead you get a dependence on n okay
so it's not sensitive to the coherence
the result doesn't get better with the
coherence okay i should say the
clearance is in general much less than n
and often you know depends on it only
mildly so having a dependence on the
currents is much better than
dependence on man but anyway it was
shown by who not by Michael and Kona
Michael couple of inconel that the error
that we get is optimal under this notion
and our algorithm also works for both
epsilon zero which is for which they
prove the the lower bound and it also
works well on Delta where you get a root
and improvement in the error bounds and
the running times nearly linea instead
of sub large larger polynomial running
on this one I what's going to be applied
by our techniques in the privacy setting
and again this is another paper that's
on the archive you want to see the the
details so these are sort of the teaser
results that if you understand the
techniques of this talk then you can
prove these these results might be nice
and so I want to talk about how we do
this okay and this is actually what I
find most interesting the main message
of this talk is that there's one
algorithmic idea one algorithmic
principle which is the noisy power
method and it solves both alternating
minimization and private SVD so we can
think of alternating minimization and
our algorithm in the privacy settings as
instances of a more general algorithm
the noisy power method and by just
analyzing the noisy power method we can
get bounds on both of these algorithms
okay you've also noticed that the
incurrence comes up in both places and
it controls the error rates in both for
both problems at least when you talk
about entry privacy Aquarians is the
fundamental parameter just like a matrix
completion where it's also the
fundamental parameter and we'll see that
actually you know the techniques that
Aaron and I developed in the privacy
setting for for this problem they
actually solve some of the problems in
alternating minimization so some of the
techniques that were developed in the
privacy setting help us get provable
bounds in the alternating minimization
setting it's nice that you know we can
use privacy things that we came up for
four in the privacy setting outside of
privacy okay so this is the main message
I want you all to remember that because
that's sort of what I'm most excited
about um so let me talk about the noisy
power method okay what is the noise of
power
it's essentially an algorithmic template
okay so don't think of it as an
algorithm it's more like a template that
you instantiate so the way this works is
you have an input matrix that is n by n
and symmetric the symmetric the
assumption is symmetric is essentially
without loss of generality so for both
settings it's very easy to ensure and
you also given a parameter K this is the
number of singular vectors you want to
get right okay so the way the algum
starts is that initially you you just
guess an N by K matrix X 0 which is just
a random orthonormal matrix nothing
nothing fancy here it's n by K and then
you iterate 40 steps for capital T steps
you do the following in every step
nature which is working against you
nature chooses a perturbation G sub T ok
and what you get to observe in every
round is a matrix Y sub t which is equal
to the product of a and x of t minus of
t minus 1 plus the perturbation that was
may be adversely chosen by nature ok so
think of it as power method would just
be a times x of t minus one noisy power
method has this extra perturbation that
we don't necessarily get to choose an
approach saying we get to choose it in
altman we don't so think of it as nature
choosing that perturbation and then we
also normalize the matrix so we make
sure that all the columns of xt are unit
vectors and orthogonal to each other and
that's the whole algorithm then on the
end after capital T steps you you just
output X of T as your as your
approximation to the top K singular
vectors does it make sense is the
element clear too simple it's too simple
people not okay so yeah this algorithm
is is quite simple um and it's actually
the analysis is quite nice and pretty
and it uses an idea of a principle
angles ok so the way you're going to
analyze this elder is that you define an
angle a notion of angle between
subspaces and you argue that as you go
along the subspace that you have the
subspace spanned by X of T approaches
the subspace that you want in this angle
distance
okay so how do you define an angle
between subspaces it's actually
everything you know about vectors
carries through okay so if you if you
only know vectors that's fine it's it's
it's good enough that intuition okay so
remember if k is equal to 1 then you and
X are just vectors okay they're just
n-dimensional vectors and so the cosine
of the angle between you and X is just
defined as well the inner product
between you and X in absolute value okay
so pictorially you know you and X are
just vectors the cosine is just the
length of this projection of X onto you
okay and that's exactly more or less
what you do for four subspaces so in
general if K is bigger than one you
define the cosine of the angle between
you and X as the smallest single a
vector of the matrix u transpose X
notice that's the same as you know what
we had before for k equals to 1 in
general now u transpose X is AK by K
matrix it has k singular values and you
look at the smallest one okay so that's
the cosine of the angle between two
subspaces so just as a sanity check
suppose that this matrix this K by K
matrix has a zero singular value okay so
the angle is is is the cosine of zero
right the cosine of the angle so sort of
X is orthogonal to you in this matrix
case it means that there is a nonzero
vector in X which is orthogonal to you
okay so in some sense that should mean
that these subspaces are in a sense
orthogonal okay we have cosine cosine
that is zero okay there's no correlation
there's a nonzero vector in one that's
with ordinal 12 to the entire subspace
okay so that's the the the definition
you can also define sign the sine of the
angle similarly here what you do is you
look at the matrix V transpose X where V
is the orthogonal complement of you and
you look at the largest singular value
of Regents pro-sex okay and again you if
you draw a V to be this like this this
vertical line orthogonal to you then it
corresponds to the length of the
projection of X onto onto V okay
and you can check that you actually have
one equals sine squared plus cosine
squared as you would expect from a
definition of angles so this is all very
nice and almost anything that you can
say about vectors still to refer
matrices and the main notion that we're
going to use in the convergence analysis
actually the tangent okay so we're going
to combine sine and cosine into 11
functioned the tangent of the angle
which is the ratio of sine and cosine
and the tension has suffering corporates
all the information there is and it's
the right potential function to look at
okay so what is the main convergence
lemma for the noisy power method here is
what you can show and it's not hard to
show let's first consider the case where
GT is equal to 0 the perturbation is
equal to 0 so it's noise free let's
suppose we analyze a noise-free power
method then what you can show us that
the tangent between you and XT so the
tangent at step t is less than the
tangent at step t minus 1 times the
factors sigma k plus 1 over sigma k ok
so the tangents just sine over cosine
where i've written here is the tangent
times a number that's always less or
equal than one this number is always
less or equal than one this ratio this
ratio is the tangent so you just get the
detention that step T is some number
less or equal to 1 times the tangent at
the previous step very natural so the
convergence rate is just a ratio of
these these numbers convergence is to
the subspace spanned by the tops that's
exactly right that's exactly right to
the subspace so it mean it may not be
the case that the vectors individually
approach each other but the subspace of
all gets closer that's a great question
um yeah Adam if you don't have a gap
between Sigma
+ 1 and Sigma K presumably you can still
make nice statements about absolutely
and this the same analysis in fact goes
through and what you're going to do
instead is that you choose the dimension
of XT and you to be different so you can
argue things like how quickly converge K
vectors to the top to k singular vectors
and then you would only get a gap
between K and 2k plus 1 so you can
generalize this to account for
situations where you don't have a gap
same same picture it's just slightly
more difficult math okay so now what
happens if you have noise it's quite
nice it's sort of exactly what you would
expect just four minutes oh god and you
said you were going to serious about
enforcing time okay so it's exactly what
you would expect so the sign gets
perturbed by the projection of the noise
term on TV and the cosine gets perturbed
by the projection of GT on to you which
is you know pictorially exactly what you
expect this is this length since the
cosine it gets perturbed by the
projection of g2g t on to this axis this
is the sign it gets perturbed by the
projection of GT on to this axis so it's
exactly what you would expect your
metrically and that's the main lemma so
what can we do with this we can you know
we have the hammer we just need the
nails now and I realize I'm a little bit
over you know behind but so basically
you can analyze alternating minimization
so what the way alternating minimization
works is that you know you get a
subsample of entries from an unknown
matrix and you want to find the unknown
matrix so you want to find the dominant
singular vectors of the unknown matrix
and the way you do this is by solving a
least square step iteratively so at
every step you find a matrix Y T which
on the observed observed examples so we
shall denote by P Omega this is the
projection onto the sample minimizes the
Frobenius square error between a and the
matrix that you have so which is XT
minus 1 times y transpose so this is an
n-by-n matrix you minimize the distance
between these matrices overall why
notice this is convex because xt minus 1
is fixed in the only minimize / y that's
why this is a convex program and you can
solve it efficiently then you also
normalize weiss of tea
and you go on okay so essentially on a
high level what it does at every step it
fits it fits a rank a approximation to
the matrix with respect to the observed
entries and you repeatedly do that and
hope that you converge okay so good in
the end you output the last matrix that
you obtained so okay if you've never
seen this before it looks a little bit
weird all you need to know is that this
update step that you do an alternating
minimization it can be written as a
noisy power method update step why is
that well if you had full information so
if P Omega was everything you just knew
every single entry of the matrix then
the solution to this least square
problem would just be matrix vector
multiplication so you would just get
that Y sub T is equal to a times x of t
minus 1 okay and so with noise we can
essentially do the same we can say well
if it works act it would just be the
poem method but now you have this weird
sampling error in there so it's the
power method plus the sampling error
essentially at a high level okay so the
main hurdle is if you want to apply the
convergence limo we need to control the
norm of G sub T and the way the norm is
controlled if you do the analysis it's
controlled by the coherence of this
iterate okay so at every step the
coherence of this iterate xt minus one
tells you what the norm of GCT is going
to be and so you need to control that
and that's actually a difficult part
because how do you relate the coherence
of this guy to the coherence of the
underlying matrix okay and so what you
want is that if a is incoherent then
every a turret is also include here this
is the main property you need for
incoherent and we can we can argue this
based on ideas that Aaron and I
developed in the privacy setting so you
can show that there's some technique
called smooth or tautomerization from
from this paper with Aaron that I can
can go into which will give you this
coherence propagation property so we can
show that all the iterates that you come
up with they keep they stay in coherent
if the original matrix incoherent all
the interests are incoherent if all the
iterates are incoherent you have low
sample complex
so that's how the analysis goes good so
there's also something you can do in the
privacy setting it's a different
argument that again was first used by
Aaron myself and another paper and then
we i can now generalize to the to the K
dimensional case so to recap this is the
important picture the noisy power
methods very powerful it solves both of
these very nice problems in my opinion
and you know there's technology transfer
between these applications in machine
learning privacy that I find quite
interesting and that did sort of manage
to finish on time Cynthia's knowledge is
not going to kill me I I'm glad to live
another day so here are some conclusions
and open problems just briefly so
somehow what what's actually happened a
lot of this workshop is that we see that
robustness or stability is kind of the
common denominator between privacy and
machine learning and one thing I really
like is to sort of find the right robust
analysis of fundamental algorithms like
power method gradient descent and so on
even though these algorithms are so old
in that case of power method there was
actually a lot to be learned from
understanding the robustness of the
algorithm and this is also something
that pratik suggested last yesterday to
get a good robust analysis of gradient
descent so there are lots of technical
problems here you can come talk to me
afterwards can give you some more you
know here's a list or you can ask me
questions I really want to finish now
all right thanks
yeah cover them the sample size is the
reason for the sample size found being
large you to some cases because that's
what the algorithm needs to get
something that looks to have a sample
where is it that's right that you don't
get uniform convergence Vanessa normally
you have some thing where the fight is
out there by my algorithm to find
something that looks good on the sample
the sample will be actually correct
overall I think it's it's mainly the
sample complexity comes into two to
control the norm of the error term so
the convergence rate kind of depends on
these projections of the error term and
it you know you really want that to
drive you can drive that down using more
samples and the difficulty here is that
the algorithms is iterative so the way
you analyze a nuclear norm is just you
you analyze about a global optimum here
you have to sort of do it step by step
and there's so it's with fewer samples
the algorithm or even on the samples
yeah you don't even you can't even argue
that in one step you get you get
progress yeah Adam the form of the
algorithm you gave it I our state
correctly its matrix a has to be
symmetric right that's right is there is
there a like a net a natural
generalization yeah so the way that's
what's usually done is if you have a
rectangular matrix you just do sort of
be this doesn't look like the right
thing transpose and then you you know
everything works with this maybe doesn't
and running foundry why oh well if he's
very vector to write I mean well it's ok
it's very skinny you mean yeah so is
what you pay for it like no baby now has
very few nonzero entries but that's
about your run but it does it does
actually because your own genetics you
can take advantage of it yeah yeah it
only depends on the input sparsity
because all you only do matrix vector
products so you only you only have to
evaluate it against the made entry said
you know you never write out this matrix
is the short answer all right and there
are other ways to deal with a symmetric
matrices ok so i should give up the
microphone